[Musica]
no dai è in vena rai e sim ben aryeh mai
e nun simm e anai e sim ben aryeh sim
ben aryeh suo mai e nun simm e nyers in
vena
ai granai e mai erano tutti noi e seamen
anai e seamen anai esso mai e na na na
na yes in vena
mai è in vena
roma iena corte nanay è in vena niet in
vena
ormai è da film
benvenuti tutti grazie a un piacere sono
cavi a romero si arrivò della spagna
farlo li tagliolo come visto sì
il modello è molto chiaro e africa non
la finlandia
sì io ho fatto un sacco di ricerca in
gara in burkina faso in senegal in
namibia è la cosa più importante per me
è mostrare che il corpo è
importantissimo il corpo e lo strumento
piu antico che noi abbiamo per fare
musica
lo posso fare tramite le mani con il
clubbing con i piedi con il torace con
tutto e questo molto importante per noi
perché il corpo non ha una parte
razionale sino di sensazioni e di e
stimolazione e questo importantissimo è
lo che io voglio trasmettere oggi per la
corsa più interessante ancora che c'è
anche la stimolazione la stimolazione
cognitiva il lobo frontale
tutto ciò che noi facciamo dove la
attenzione concentrazione pianificazione
sequenziazione contro le di impulsi e
sempre in sia stimolata con il nostro
cervello
facciamo una piccola prova che molto
interessante si alziamo la mano destra
tutti tutti con la mano destra sopra
benissimo sotto sotto sopra alla destra
benissimo sopra sotto alla sinistra
sopra sotto alla destra sopra sotto
destra sopra sotto posizione orizzontale
tutti orizzontale ho detto orizzontale
questo verticale che è successo che ha
successo che è successo questo
importante sì sì questo si chiama
resistenza la interferenza che questo
importantissimo io ti ho dato sì un
codice di lavoro di movimento pro dopo
con la visione con il movimento te lo
posso cambiare subito adesso con due
mani
lo facciamo tutti con due mani benissimo
benissimo io dedico una lettera per
esempio a devi fare un club in a a a
b grazie a a m a a g ok adesso
aggiungiamo a clap in b cosce con due
mani attenzioni preparati sin nessuno
dorme e fantastico a b m a srb a a rbc
con la gamba destra c con la gamba
destra preparati impreparati a b c c b
ah ok a r s b a ccc che ha successo
benissimo resistenza interferenza questo
importantissimo nella parte visuale tipo
fare il sì una stimolazione molto molto
molto forte e per quello così per noi è
lì e lì il corpo e la visione che noi
abbiamo è importantissimo come lo
facciamo con movimento ti voglio e
stimolare e l'arte degli strumenti super
importanti per sapere come io muovere il
corpo così poco a poco e anche lo
facciamo con la nuova tecnologia io
sempre che viaggia africa io faccio
sempre una cosa viaggio anche con l'aipa
faccio una foto alla tribù e se la giro
e si guardano subito e che succede
questo sì riflessione per noi della
nostra epoca la fotografia era per
ricordare oggi la nuova generazione per
comunicare e questo molto molto
importante per la stimolazione con
movimento con un pensiero africano e
anche importantissimo ci alziamo tutti
ci alziamo in piedi in piedi benissimo
tutte le mani tutti così perfetto
perfetto perfetto con due mani si alza
benissimo
ok si può vedermi perfetto perché adesso
facciamo un racket che tu quanti
la plus cosce piene di piedi club la e
la rafle cosce piedi e bla bla storace
cosce i piedi e non si ferma non si
ferma non si ferma e non si ferma avanti
avanti più forte più forte forte il
piede
chi è forte fantastico 7 bravissimi non
ti puoi fermare non ti puoi fermare non
ci sarà bellissimo non ti fermi non tifa
rino di farmi continua continuano
continuato una perfetta continua
continua senza stop
[Applauso]
dov'è
forti piedi forse è
[Applauso]
1 2 3 1 2 tutti insieme perfetto
seguente seguente seguente perfetto
senza problemi un perfetto perfetto
attenzione attenzione il seguente solo
cosce solo cosce sulla coscia
adesso silenzi tutti solo cosce seguente
avanti set
[Applauso]
esco un applauso hanno fatto tutti molto
bene
perfetto no no no no no no no tutti in
piedi perché tutti in piedi si benissimo
e adesso il movimento super importante
perché adesso arriva una parte
importantissima per noi che si chiama la
stimolazione cognitiva per quello io
sempre ho una visione che come l'africa
c è sempre un doppio senso un doppio
senso che ogni volta se ha pensato come
il terzo mondo però io ho pensato quasi
sempre che forse quando io viaggia
l'africa viaggia il futuro perché noi
abbiamo una struttura di vita qua che
tutto frammentata e di là io vedo che
tutto unito è collegato sì adesso io lo
faccio della seguente manera viviamo che
c'è un piccolo quadrato il quadrato che
vedi qua che queste io devo fare
semplicemente 1 2 3 e 4 è avanti avanti
indietro è indietro e avanti avanti
dietro è avanti avanti indietro è avanti
avanti preparati per la stimolazione
cognitiva il tuo livello attenzionale
mamma mia e juan
il club solo uno e adesso tutto solo sul
112 e sono due
solo nel 2 e nel ii è adesso due avesse
enel uno solo e nel 3 solo nel 3 1 2
solo nel 3 e nel 4 perfetto 12 e 12 solo
uno solo uno e adesso cantiamo una
canzone molto molto molto molto molto
molto conosciuta calice fra martino
campanaro dormi tu dormi to suona le
campane suona le campane di donda 12 fra
martino solo uno dormi tudor mi.to suona
le campane suona le campane di don dan
stop una prossima l'hanno fatto molto
bene
perfetto no no no no ai piedi piede
preparati benissimo adesso devo alzare
la mano destra e devo alzare la mano
destra si alzo la mano destra perfetto
alla mano destra ha un nuovo nome che si
chiamata come si chiama la mano destra
benissimo sempre a domanda risposta siot
di cota che mi devi dire te benissimo
però anche devi fare un piccolo
movimento che devi strisciare per primo
io te lo faccio né dopo te sarebbe ta ta
ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta
l'altra mano preparati e si chiama chi
chi chi chi chi chi chi chi datata kiki
takita tataki e adesso arriva il mambo
number five perché lo devi fare con un
quadrato lo devi fare con un quadrato si
preparati hai mangiato bene hai mangiato
bene benissimo tutti inquadrato one two
ballammo inquadrato 1 e 2 dietro e
dietro e avanti avanti dietro dietro è
attenzione divisa due compiti si per le
donne questo facilissimo sono capace di
fare 20 8 cose si perfetto avanti avanti
indietro e indietro e ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta
chi chi chi chi chi chi adesso tutti
super preparati non si ferma il pieno si
ferma mai mai deve prendere le mani le
mani le mani della coppia perfetto
perfetto lo che hai fatto virtuale
adesso devi e stringere la mano destra
avanti avanti indietro e indietro e
avanti avanti e indietro indietro
preparati tutti attenzione attenzione è
stata data a destra chi chi chi chi chi
preparati
takita chi
stuckey takita tataki
dotata chi chi chi è sto pure provato
fatto davvero benissimo adesso sì che
questa mattina
benissimo benissimo benissimo benissimo
perfetto lo hanno fatto molto molto
molto molto bene questo molto importante
per noi perché la stimolazione che noi
abbiamo tramite il corpo è
importantissimo che abbiamo visto che si
facciamo delle piccole pillole di
movimento si con un alto livello di
concentrazione di attenzione si può
avere la stimolazione noi lavoriamo
moltissimo con persone sane anche con
persone con parkinson alzheimer e danni
cerebrali ictus loro la questo molto
importante per noi perché sappiamo che
con questo tipo di attività c'è una cosa
molto importante e l'apprendimento e
ludico è la cosa più importante non sono
per imparare dove soffro c'è un momento
dove io posso imparare 3 c'è una gioia
c'è un livello di ossitocina sì la
calandra pituitaria che stimolo un sacco
di ormone per quello che abbiamo qua il
lobo frontale si è la parte molto molto
molto sviluppata in questa parte però io
pianificare sequenziare lo che io ho
imparato a bere semplicemente un
controllo di impulso un'altra cosa super
super interessante anche se il movimento
la pianificazione dello che io devo fare
e anche con il mio comportamento e anche
con la società per quello a noi sempre
abbiamo un senso del primo va il corpo
dopo va la testa primo sento e dopo la
parte razionale la parte cognitiva la
parte dove io io penso al cento per
cento
questo molto importante perché il
movimento che sempre facciamo deve
essere collegato a una parte di
stimolazione de l'astre mita superiore
l'estremità inferiore e soprattutto con
la voce e noi sempre facciamo una
ricerca gigantissimo che è fatta sempre
la scuola media elementare è anche
soprattutto con persone con diversi tipi
di patologia per provare per stimolare e
per ricercare fare un aiuto senza sì la
pillola e soprattutto di una forma la
forma più naturale al 100 per cento che
noi abbiamo fatto è semplicemente una
piccola introduzione dove sempre tramite
lavori per caso
la neuro motricità va bene è
importantissimo sapere come se stimola
il corpo che lo posso fare di una
maniera molto molto è strutturata alla
fine la cosa più importante che io
voglio trasmettere è che la forma
sequenziale di apprendimento cambia e in
diverse culture
la prima volta che io sono stato per
esempio la burkina faso un attribuiti
camana volongo ho visto un sacco di
gente con il djembe fu cut cut cut sono
andato subito e ho detto prendo anche un
djembe e voglio anche imparare e sono
andato là e io le ho detto me puoi
insegnare
sì sì che non c'è problemi ok lui che mi
dice primo ritmo prodotto contoconto com
content con un tocco e io ho detto stop
non posso farlo e come facciamo
la mia risposta lo facciamo e come lo
facciamo è la è la mia terra e lui mi
dice come la tua terra è la mia terra è
che te fai tutto cio come io faccio
attaccata comune dice no no no 4 devi
imparare completo intero questo è
impossibile per sio va la grana
l'andalusia per imparare il flamenco non
c'è un livello 1 di bulleri a livello 2
di bulleri a livello 3 così di bulleri a
apprendi la buleria così con il flamenco
però non è tutto frammentato e questo
super importante la cosa più curiosa che
lui subito mi chiede e te che fai e la
tua terra quel tuo lavoro
io sono insegnanti di musica lui lui che
mi guarda e io le ho detto guarda io
faccio questo sai è la mia vita io
mangio così di questo quando gliel'ho
detto lui che io sì che io faceva musica
per lui è stato come un insegnante di
andare al bar a bere il caffè della
forma più normale questo le ha colpito
moltissimo perché ha visto che veramente
che la musica la parte cinestetica il
movimento era all'interno di una cultura
che si trasmette giorno a giorno sempre
in tutti i momenti della vita di forma
normale
noi lo facciamo di forma frammentata
dove devo andare una scuola di che mi fa
il ballo di e lo faccio con una e
struttura molto interessante per quello
per noi questo è importantissimo così
sapere e trasmettere che forse il
modello non è finlandia il modello può
essere africa il modello e africa perché
ha una cultura di struttura molto chiara
molto gruppale molto di tribù di
lavorare insieme inclusiva cooperativa
si non di competizione e questo molto
molto importante per sapere per creare
altri tipi di comunità dove non c'è
sempre una competizione si la cosa più
importante è anche che il corpo sempre
diventa una forma della nostra
trasmissione de cómo io mi sento della
emozione e la parte africana sempre mia
aiuta sempre per farlo mani sopra
facciamo così
tutta la vita
che so mai e tutti
yeah yeah
meyer
ormai è forte
yeah yeah
meyer
semmai è più forte chi è
lo sci club
yeah yeah yeah yeah meyer
mai e forse
meyer
[Musica]
il suo meyer
[Applauso]
meyer
[Musica]
[Applauso]
meyer chiave
lei
meyer
ormai è forte
adesso meyer
insomma
bene per finire la parte più importante
per me l'obiettivo finale e le scopo che
una insegnante non trasmette il sapere
ma solo lei storia d'amore o di
crepacuore che avete con la vostra
disciplina e questo è la cosa più
importante che io voglio trasmettere
ti ricordi quando sei è stato e l'asilo
nido il contenuto che ti hanno dato è
molto difficile è vero però sicuro che
no è dimenticato come ti ha fatto
sentire l'insegnante e questo è la cosa
più importante che noi abbiamo la
possibilità di fare sentire molto bene
con energia molto positiva dove il corpo
il ritmo
la musica è forse una struttura africana
dove il modello può essere africa in un
finlandia come strumento di lavoro nella
nostra scuola nella nostra università in
tutta la struttura educativa
grazie un piacere
[Applauso]